pink how many of you are um Heroes have
you met like I know Madonna was a big
influence for you you admired her career
do you know her are you friends with
some of these people you are not Madonna
doesn't like me I don't know why why
wouldn't she like it some people just
don't like me
how do you know she doesn't I don't
understand it no I do understand it I'm
apologizing individual but when Don is a
polarizing individual she is man
right
well I think that um she tried to kind
of play me on on Regis and Kelly and I
didn't I'm not you know I'm not the one
so it didn't work out what does that
mean I think she tried to play well it's
just such a silly story because I
actually I I [__] love Madonna and
right
I love her no matter what like I I still
love her I love her no matter what she
was such an inspiration to me but it
sort of got twisted around that I was
like fangirling and and was dying to
meet Madonna when I in actuality she
invited me into her dressing room
and so I just said a joke when Regis
brought me out he's like how does it
feel to me like I mean I heard you're
just falling over yourself backstage how
does it feel I'm like I thought she
wanted to meet me
so she took that personally I wish you
listen I got a surprise for you
Madonna's here and she's going to fight
you now you're gonna go three rounds
and it's going to be great